we you do a good example I feel like I
mean with the chips the Cologne I mean
everything you try to I feel like lead
by an example of your work ethic and the
way that you create your own
infrastructure for yourself you know
everything is that has to do with you it
feels like runs through you and that
gives you control over it do you where
do you feel like you got that kind of
business that kind of business mind
because I have a problem with Hollywood
- it's one of the reasons why I started
are in the studio right because so we
can make our own stuff I don't like I
don't like a company that I don't even
know these [ __ ] own in a part
of me telling me how I can look how I
can behave right um and we've prospered
man like we sell out tickets mean I sell
we did I did a world tour last year you
know I'm not bragging but we did it on
our own because I don't like somebody
own and I don't like somebody owning a
piece of me I don't like somebody
exploiting me right uh so I can only
imagine kind of the level that that
feels like on a to a black person you
know right right a lot of people a lot
of people a lot of people look at my
husband a value you know because I ain't
letting [ __ ] get over me you
know I know I know what I can do I know
you know so everything I mean I got on
the ship there's not one thing I mean
that I don't have them [ __ ] yeah you
know I'm not no promoted and think I'm
not going to promote your brand clothes
you know and this is on Instagram right
that's a business that's a business you
know I get paid for that but uh nice I
gotta have ownership because uh you know
once you sell it you know I guess
nothing you might want to sell it today
and I guess nothing so I gotta have
ownership yeah that's just how I am in
it and I'm in a position to do that you
know I give money I drop a city every
month I got married money I'm
independent yeah so you know I mean I
don't gotta take a couple crumbs from
nobody cuz I'm all ready to sell him
eight yeah that's nice isn't it yeah if
it feels good when your chicks coming to
you yeah and a lot I do have to pay
do you feel sometimes because this is a
side effect of my the way I operate
I do feel sometimes I feel left out by
the mainstream do you ever feel that
yeah always I always been they've always
tried to put me out of the mainstream
Boosie made it to the mainstream Qaboos
it made it to the mainstream you know I
came out I was 14 you know 15 years old
98 I didn't get on BT - Oh 403 yeah Oh 4
so you know how though I'm talking now I
mean I feel like you've taken on a whole
different I mean it's your up you gotta
understand you got to understand the way
the way I've came home and turned into
ultra preneur platinum me on side of
them I'm a threat to [ __ ]
I gotta help myself by me having
ownership and [ __ ] it's not like that
nobody's gonna help you like that yeah
cuz they could be jealous you know David
you don't get help from [ __ ]
who who can really help you you know
you're not gonna get that because they
know you're a threat to them you know
and I and I feel like that in so many
ways you know I'm left out a lot of [ __ ]
but I don't dick ride right you know I
don't climb I don't need you know I
don't want anybody else's help
you know I don't I don't need to hang
they get to get nothing
yeah if it don't come to me God ain't
God ain't make it for me that's how I
feel so I'm just you know I'm just I'm
just boosting man and they can't stop it
and once you gotta follow it and once
you got a I got a cult following people
love me it's crazy brah dude there were
times when I even we get I'll be like I
there was a little I'll be honest I
didn't love you anymore bro yeah and I
[ __ ] real of you yeah so bro like you
could be loved twice man like that's how
much that's a whole you don't
like that is how I think that's a sense
of attraction that you had evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watches one